it's like thousands even would our car
reviewer Emmanuelle will be testing
Ford's new second-generation s-max the
first generation was crowned european
car of the year in 2007 the recent
revamp is immediately evident from the
exterior it still exhibits Ford's design
language familiar from the Fiesta and
the Mondeo it gives the car a broader
and sporty-er look
from the side the s-max seems stretched
this impression is enhanced by the way
the windows descend toward the back and
featured on but now familiar keyless go
feature explains him on a while allowed
you to leave the key in your pocket the
s-max you merely have to lay your hand
on the handle and the door will open
automatically and when you get out of
the car again just place a finger on
those four lines and the door locks
likewise automatically does ultra-feast
automatic up PS max appeals to drivers
who like a more aggressive drive this is
reflected in the available engines
manual is driving the version with the
largest available gasoline unit the 2.0
liter ecoboost which generates 175
kilowatts our s max accelerates the 109
point 4 seconds and reaches a top speed
of 226 km/h ford claims a fuel economy
of 7.9 liters of gas per 100 kilometers
with power like that it's easy to end up
going faster than you realize here too
Ford has a solution bebes death machine
in the past to avoid exceeding the speed
limit you could turn on the speed
regulation device and it kept you under
the permissible pace but the device was
unaware of when the speed limit changed
now a camera in the second generation s
Max's intelligent speed limiter
recognizes traffic signs plus the GPS
navigation system knows the speed limits
on different stretches of Road the
system adjusts the cars top speed
accordingly that's temple on the system
also recognizes no overtaking signs and
displays them on the instrument cluster
the interior incorporates high quality
materials and exhibits sound
craftsmanship
all the buttons are easily accessible so
you can easily switch the numerous
assistance systems on or off such as
parking assistant park distance control
and the automatic start/stop system
bacon doesn't eat everyone has been in a
parking space at 90 degrees to the
street with the other parked cars
blocking the view you have to stretch
far forward to see if anyone's coming
but the s-max has a front camera for a
180-degree view so approaching cars are
seen at a comfortable glance the rear of
the s-max is even more dynamic than its
predecessor the LED rear lights boast a
rather unique design especially in the
dark but the design isn't all that has
changed I'll another familiar situation
is carrying things to the car and not
wanting to set them down I think it gets
off too easy just move your foot under
here and the easy-open function opens
the hatch automatically Connie says
district yup if you put your first piece
of cargo in and there's not enough room
for much more then just press this
button and the third row seats folds
down for more story space what's mine to
take I lon that's consoles me there's
also a button for the second row seats
fitted with the entry level 1.5 liter
gasoline engine the s-max starts at
thirty thousand one hundred fifty euros
in Germany for diesel units are
available along with another gasoline
engine overall emmanuel likes the s-max
it has a fresh design is extremely
functional and has a wealth of assists
if life begins at forty then let rival
car makers be where the BMW 3 series has
been continually evolving over six
generations
3-series is a very much to the core of
our brand and you know it started back
in the mid-70s it started the longest
success period and I think automotive
history some 14 million 3-series have
been sold around the world since that
point and of course today comes in in
many derivatives as well so its core in
the United States its core in in Asia
and it's also cool here in Europe so
we're delighted with this positioning
and what better place to unveil the
latest sedan and touring sports wagon
versions than the BMW museum in Munich
it's home to various historical models
including the beginnings of the 3-series
the enduring success story began back in
1975 BMW launched a car that would have
a defining influence on generations of
drivers a compact mid-range model with
both executive and sporting ambitions
and with exterior and interior styling
that was truly innovative a driver
oriented front cabin would be a
characteristic feature of BMWs new baby
the 3-series would also soon leave its
mark on the track to at home in Germany
and on the international racing circuit
maybe was not one of the best was of the
best car for touring car and with it car
we could achieve magnetite us we won
immediately 1987 we want the world to
link our championship and 98 that we
want a European and then in 80 89 we
want a DTM so was a fantastic period for
racing with with its car and the
engineers have given a 3-series a nice
makeover in time for its big birthday of
course the interior has seen a series of
changes over the last four decades
upgraded materials plus electronic
assists and other features that leave
nothing to be desired what has remained
is the driver friendly front cabin
then there's the one edition of the
three series that was originally not
really part of BMWs plans but is today
an integral part of the legend the
Turing sports wagon Douglas wall neyo la
vie de gallo it came about due to max
rice Burks family vacations whenever he
wanted to take his wife and children on
vacation there was the problem of
packing in all the luggage in the
regular 3-series notchback he was both a
BMW engineer and a keen BMW driver so in
april nineteen eighty-four he began
thinking about how to build a wagon
version call me decided to shift back
the c-pillar and extend the roof he
could already picture it remaining
hopeful for many the 3-series was and is
more than just a means of transportation
it's a way of life the 3-series was soon
in big demand among collectors Daniel
falconback is the owner of one of the
most comprehensive collections of the
three series
you fussing at Sony the model exerts an
amazing attraction he explains because
it's such a versatile car compared with
many others it's agile responsive and
has a really wide range of uses he just
loves it that's foul on pagar Samantha
that takes a closer look to detect new
changes on the exterior at the front the
trademark kidney grille has gotten wider
and the lights have been modernized
front and back in both the sedan and
wagon versions
the changes under the hood are more
obvious the top of the range engine is a
3 liter 6 cylinder unit in the BMW 340 I
it delivers 240 kilowatts of power and
acceleration from 0 to 100 km/h and 5.2
seconds top speed is an electronically
limited 250 km/h official fuel
consumption is a 7.7 liters of premium
unleaded for 100 kilometers not bad a
first for the 3 series is a 1.5 liter
three-cylinder engine in the 389 BMW
claims of fuel economy of just five
liters for 100 kilometers but still with
a peak speed of 210 km/h a plug-in
hybrid edition is slated for launch in
2016
see God has given the beats of facelift
under the hood you'll now find
supercharged 3-cylinder engines which
comply with the Euro 6 emission standard
and they've made it even easier to stay
connected with avisas new mirror link
and Apple play features the design
hasn't changed but there will be color
packs available meaning the wheel rims
radiator grille and mirrors now come in
any of six shiny new colors the launch
of the first q7 back in 2006 marked
Audi's breakthrough into the SUV market
since then the car maker has sold more
than 2 million q models half a million
of these work you sevens their largest
SUV model and it's now time for the
second generation the new version is
around 300 25 kilograms lighter and has
new more efficient engines that use up
to twenty eight percent less fuel
volkswagen presents the new gulf our
variate for the first time with an
extended rear it packs 221 kilowatts of
power and up to 380 newton meters of
torque the standard 6-speed dual-clutch
gearbox progressive steering and sports
suspension lowered by two centimeters
make it a real high performance little
wagon
the go far variant may look tame at
first sight but it's a powerhouse the
four gleaming tailpipes already hint at
that as do the big brakes to bring the
are variant to a quick stop those 221
kilowatts can produce between 5506
thousand two hundred rpm if you choose
your shift point precisely you'll be
rewarded with a loud Rumble from the
exhaust system the our wagon rockets to
100 kilometers an hour in 5.1 seconds
and has a top speed of 250 kilometers an
hour without the speed limitation device
it can reach 270
former race driver Klaus needs Fitz is
testing the are variant for us on the
seguito askari in Spain where you can
really put the meaty station wagon
through its paces the sports setting
allows the electronic stability program
to perform gentle harmonious drifts the
standard all-wheel drive also helps
transmit all the power of the
supercharged 2-liter four-cylinder
engine to the road this enforcement
Klaus says power isn't restricted to the
cars sound here you have 300 horsepower
and plenty of torque 380 Newton meters
are quite an advantage when you come out
of a turn with low revs then when you
step on the gas the car shoots ahead
testes not fought on the ESC sports
setting can be deactivated for laps on a
race track one of the emotional
highlights is the newest generation of
the DCC adaptive chassis control whose
choice of driving profiles includes a
race mode
it's all together Klaus is thrilled the
are variant reaches 260 kilometers an
hour here in the straightaway and he
says 270 is possible on the Autobahn
when you hit the brakes at that speed
you feel the seatbelt more than you'd
like but a powerful brake system is just
what a car this sporty needs spot to his
auto in the interior the Gulf flagship
boasts a three-spoke leather sports
steering wheel automatic climate control
and a large touchscreen the are variant
always comes with a direct shift gearbox
and for motion permanent four-wheel
drive only high quality materials go
into the go far and in our logo graces
the sport seats lecompton Klaus can
hardly believe this is a small van it
definitely feels like a sports car here
on the Ascari racecourse then he tests
the car at a lower speed after all it
has families in mind the kids in the
back and mom and dad in the front on
shopping trips the car and its engine
are both well suited for everyday use to
undermine calvin fallon on the attack
stylish coyotes autozone the office
motors is shown bind of it
so it does last on the Ascari racetrack
our car tester is very impressed the car
has lots of power a top-notch
transmission good brakes and precise
steering the new VW Golf R variant
offers driving fun room and safety with
a whopping 221 kilowatt engine and a
1620 liters of storage space and leaves
little to be desired in Germany the are
very it starts at 40 2925 euros
well and NZ by a Hollywood car test our
ein hawd eyes and over says most people
think of movie stars when they think of
Hollywood but there's also a tiny
village of that name population barely a
hundred in Ireland he's here to test the
new Opel Insignia the typical company
car most drivers want their office on
wheels to get from A to B quickly
quietly smoothly and economically so
he's going to see how well the insignia
powered by the whisper diesel can do
just that come show me hace esta opals
product offensive is moving ahead full
speed that includes a thorough upgrade
of the range of diesel engines the
market debut of the 2.0 cdti ushered in
a new generation of diesels and three
power outputs for Opel models from the
Corsa to the insignia the 2-liter diesel
in the insignia we testin is touted as
quieter cleaner and more fuel-efficient
the new leader of the diesel pack posts
125 kilowatts of power and 400 Newton
metres of torque adding up to four
percent more performance and fourteen
percent more torque than its predecessor
opals alpha wolf leaps from 0 to 100
km/h and 9.4 seconds reaching a top
speed of 220 km/h the car maker rates
fuel consumption as 4.7 litres per 100
kilometers
ah sequel sentence I know points out
that eighty percent of Germany's
insignia buyers choose a station wagon
and eighty-five percent won a diesel
engine the introduction of the whisper
diesel will probably increase this
number from inside the car the 170
horsepower engine is as quiet as a
gasoline-powered one and just a
sensitive in responding to the pedal HMI
stands for human machine interface a
networked front cabin through which the
driver communicates with the car that
includes the steering wheel control
interface the center consoles
touchscreen speech recognition and the
instrument cluster in front of the
driver all designed to minimize
distractions in traffic the 2-liter cdti
uses the blue injection scr system to
remove nitrogen oxide from its emissions
much as trucks do a smidgen of add blue
a mixture of urea and distilled water is
injected into the exhaust the resulting
ammonia breaks the nitrogen oxide down
into harmless nitrogen and steam
the arrested easily move Reinhold
concludes that the whisper diesel is a
whole new generation it has more power
and accelerates better than its
predecessor and it produces less
vibration it could be a tad sporty-er
but the Insignia is a bit too porky for
that if it were lighter it would be
nimble er peers when he carries weight
the 1972 Porsche 911 targa is 14 purists
no digital gimmickry no fancy assists
just pure engineering and mechanics it's
brimming with power and panache many
things about it may seem out of date but
never old
the targa followed no Trent this is
truly a classic of the timeless variety
which counts for so much more
its form followed a concept and the
principle of craftsmanship not
computer-aided design the Porsche 911
was a dream out of reach for most
drivers budgets when first launched it
was the mark of a successful man or
woman now as a vintage car it remains an
exclusive asset affordable only to a
select few
the previous owner of this 911 targa put
some forty thousand euros into it not to
buy it but just to restore it the window
of opportunity for getting hold of an
original 911 on the chief closed long
ago sometime around the early 1990s at
the latest the prices have been climbing
ever since as long as the overall
condition to sound especially of the
body even a fairly expensive renovation
can be well worth the investment
the interior is likewise a
straightforward affair reduced to the
technical essentials for a
high-performance sports car
the air-cooled engine has an
irresistible sound a masterpiece of
old-school engineering an early Targa
like this is not meant for showing on
fans of lowriding Ronnie sounding cool
might prefer other models the targa has
a style of its own of a pedigree sports
car and that means a driver to match one
with the power to put a foot on the
brakes and some muscle into the non
power steering
so I'd pasa vintage car collector marcos
diamant confirms that this kind of
Porsche is not for wimps it means work
and contact with the road something for
enthusiasts it's not state-of-the-art
Porsche with driver assists this car has
a certain firmness and sturdiness so you
know you're in a sports car with the
open sky above you that's the unique
charm of the targa does Martin buzon de
and Isis targets ours
this 911 is not the best entry model
into classy car circles for one the
handling takes some getting used to and
for another repairs and maintenance are
in the same price class as the car
itself
portia rolled out the first 911 targa in
1965 and the form of a highly
safety-conscious convertible at the time
the a-pillars did without reinforced
high strength materials had not yet been
developed instead the engineers put a
stainless steel clad roll bar in behind
the front seats no other car at the time
had one what started as a practical but
ugly solution later became the targus
trademark
the targa stop was detachable but in the
long run that meant extra wear and tear
if there was no room left under the
front hood it could also be stood behind
the seats by the lighting cell phone
Marcus diamants passion for vintage cars
is partly to do with his distaste for
today's vehicles especially because they
tend to look increasingly alike back
when cars were developed mainly by the
engineers they were the ones who
determine the final product today in his
opinion the marketing people have far
too much say in it now what's important
is what the market demands not what the
brand represents today all the cars have
the same shape an egg shape rounded off
every car used to have its own
personality so you could spot the model
from the horizon vintage cars put you
into a time machine and give you a feel
for what life was like 40 years ago
machine is a test when assaulted an
online perfect into standard than food
mizuki nazovi deloitte as he forfeits
economy food hub the 1972 Porsche Targa
has no problem handling everyday driving
but the driver might have problems
handling the target it takes work
there's no time to relax sit back and
enjoy the ride but even if the tea lines
130 horsepower engine is noticeably
weaker than the S lines 190 horsepower
it's still fun to drive and as fast as
anyone's likely to need